in 1986 the late John Hughes gave film
audiences one of his most beloved teen
drama DS and teen heroes filled with
memorable scenes zippy one-liners and a
motley cast of characters Ferris
Bueller's Day Off is a film that not
only stands the test of time but helped
define a genre but watch this classic
again as an adult and you realize that
more than a few parts of the movie are
actually pretty cartoonish and require a
serious suspension of disbelief here are
just a few examples unbelievable toys
from his totally ba stereo to his killer
IBM computer and beyond
Ferris has a bedroom that would make him
the envy of any 80's teen hi Ferris
how's your body oh my god you're dying
then there's that awesome synthesizer he
uses to make convincing fart and vomit
sound effects while rallying the troops
at school it's an emu emulator to the
creme de la creme of synths used by 80s
bands like Depeche Mode it would have
set Faris's parents back about eight
grand an insane price tag considering
there's no evidence Ferris even knows
how to really play it or any other
instrument or that his parents are quite
that well-off never had one lesson wacky
wardrobe there's-- changes his outfit
and absurd nine times before Cameron
even picks him up in the morning pulling
looks out of the ether like Bugs Bunny
all before 10 a.m.
theorises assorted looks range from PJs
to pool attire from luau gear to hip
jazz cat various states of undress
coming to and from the shower plus his
blue suit that he plans to wear to trick
mr. Rooney into thinking he Sloan's dad
time travel early in the movie Ferris
and Cameron make their phony phone call
to Ed Rooney from Pharisees house and
disagree about how to handle picking up
Sloan at school to Faris's dismay
Cameron as Sloan's dad blurts out that
mr. Rooney should have Sloan outside the
school this leads to a series of events
that would suspiciously take longer than
10 minutes
Harrison Cameron argue over the details
Ferris delivers an emotional apology and
the two are chums again they then travel
to Cameron's house where Ferris
convinces Cameron to borrow Cameron's
dad's vintage Ferrari they say
the vehicle and travel all the way to
Shermer hi somehow arriving only a
minute or so after mr. Rooney and Sloane
emerge identity crisis the biggest
mystery about Sloane Peterson is how
seamlessly she goes from utter terror
that fears his dad might spot her in the
taxi line at the restaurant to
nonchalance about making kissy faces to
mr. Bueller later from the backseat of
another taxi cab sure she has those
ray-ban sunglasses on as a brilliant
disguise but even perpetually oblivious
mr. Bueller must recognize his son's
super serious girlfriend right
considering fair's proposed to Sloane
back at the stock exchange things might
get pretty awkward at the wedding
mysterious Gipps aside from a quick
visit from mrs. Bueller to check in on
an ailing Faris and fares his sister
Jeannie's time at home when she kicks
mr. Rooney in the face and Huddle's in
her bedroom to call the police the
Bueller home is mostly empty for the day
while Faris enjoys his time off yet when
everyone comes home at 6:00 p.m. the
hallways are filled to the rafters with
the balloon and flower delivery sent by
the entire town to wish Faris a speedy
recovery
so who accepted all those deliveries it
couldn't have been Jeannie in fact we
see her slammed the door in the singing
telegram nurses face and it likely
wasn't mr. Rooney because the one vase
of flowers we saw him pick up ended up
on that head of the family's Rottweiler
despairs have a robot Butler among his
many fabulous toys the late bus Dara's
Bueller's Day Off is loaded with
brilliant moments and immensely quotable
lines but the fun doesn't stop when the
credits roll you've gotta love seeing
that disheveled and broken mr. Rooney
accepting a warm gummy bear from his
bespectacled bus seat mate set to the
unforgettably catchy strains of yellows
oh yeah I bet you never smelled a real
school bus
but when you watch it again as an adult
you realize there's something peculiar
about that school bus filled with teens
pulling up to mr. Rooney and asking him
if he needs a ride
we know it's now long past six o'clock
p.m. and those kids should have been
home hours ago
who are these kids is the driver lost
considering everything else he managed
to pull off sticking Rooney on this
bizarre bus just might beat Faris's
handiwork it's good for him it teaches
him to deal with this fear thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]